the jurgen experience did i ever tell
you i used to be on the radio
the radio yeah i've told you this before
in another life no when i was like seven
years old that was on um
kiss fm did you tell me this i have
really
yeah ryan's you crashed the most of it
probably yeah why did i
not remember that i don't know because
it was good yeah i mean i had a job
working as a radio personality for like
four years from
third grade until sixth grade
yeah making prank phone calls
no yeah i don't think you told me that i
just told you did you tell me on the air
no you told me in real life i told you
in real life i don't know if you did
i don't remember do you remember this
mm-hmm i've heard i may have heard her
talk about it before
i don't know but i was like a mini i was
like a little mini celebrity in my
hometown
you know like my dad would he i remember
one time he had to get a rental car
and they were gonna give him like you
know a toyota or something and he's like
do you listen to ksfm do you know a
little alley
that's my daughter can i get a
convertible pick me up from school in a
new
like a nicer rental car or something
yeah
yeah but i mean even that was hard and
that was like
[ __ ] did that happen i called in
randomly my sisters listened to kiss fm
when we would get ready for school we'd
listen to seven i was seven
no one's watching you my dad was home my
dad was home and my sisters were home
probably yeah and you just grabbed the
phone and started dialing numbers i
asked my sister i said i don't want to
call into the radio station
i want to like request a song or
something and my sister is like i'm not
giving you the number you're gonna
embarrass me all my friends listen to
this station
and so she tries calling in she doesn't
get through my dad takes her to school
me and my other sister at home i press
re-dial on the phone
and i immediately get through and now
i'm panicking i don't know what to say
and i'm like can i get britney spears
tickets talking to ryan seacrest and
he's like can you sing a britney spears
song
so i'm like seven years old singing
toxic by britney spears just being like
the taste of your lips i'm
on a ride and after i sing this song
he's like oh we don't have
britney spears tickets but we have
american idol tickets and i was like
i'll only go if they're vip
is that what you said yeah then we're
just having a conversation back and
forth he's like where are your parents
i'm like i don't know
dad's out it's like seven in the morning
and then i ended up getting a job making
prank phone calls for them
how did it end it ended with me not
being little anymore
and i didn't like you anymore no i was
too old i was like 12.
is that really what happened they yeah
so i had a contract that would like
you know expired and then they wanted to
renew it but
in a different way and sign on to ryan's
production company
but my dad wanted to pimp you out yeah
whoa
and you want a pcu yeah really yeah i
think a piece i think they won like 20
of everything you do from there on out i
think so
whoa and my dad was like that's too much
and so we didn't end up doing it if your
stand-up career took off
you'd be ryan seacrest [ __ ]
so for the rest of your career if you'd
sign that
it might be for life yeah but i don't
think it would have been for life
forever he produced a kardashian [ __ ]
forever and everyone i always tell my
dad we could have been the makovsky's
keeping up with the makovsky's yeah he
[ __ ] up dad no
but i'm so grateful because i mean i
don't know
if anything would have come of that or
anything but like i'm glad i got to eat
lunch in the bathroom alone in high
school and like
have all of those you know just awkward
moments weird awkward
uncomfortable moment isn't that funny
that at the time you think of them as
being the worst thing ever
and then later on you realize there's
kind of a gift in some of that weird
angst
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other
apps and can download episodes to save
on data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience